[Music]
please welcome everybody Ike Baron Holtz
Ike
[Applause]
[Music]
barol just stay like this for 12
minutes so I understand you're on The
Mindy Project yeah it's been pretty
exciting pretty exciting season
cool yeah is is that a real hospital no
it's actually a set at Universal Studios
oh Orlando Florida no no no right across
Barum oh my yeah oh I was thinking of
the one with the rides no no no there's
there's an amusement park portion of it
but that's totally separate common
mistake Pete do
you you're really you're really sweating
I know I'm generating so many BT I know
it's hot lot of did you see the Matrix
uh only the
sequels I was I was lost I was lost did
you watch Lost yes the series yes yes
nice they were all in
purgatory oh the whole time is that what
it
was
right solid B hey me
right solid bit I want to thank you for
having me on as your first guest of your
first
episode I brought you a gift I
okay I last minute I was going to get
you a gift card I got you some
crackers these look glutenfree they are
gluten-free wait one is gluten-free one
has extra gluten it's like a horrible
kind of like that ioane powder scene
it's better not be the which one is the
gluten
that's Wallace sha from The Princess
Bride any anybody anybody want a peanut
that's Andre the Giant from The Princess
Bride uh why didn't you give me a paper
cut and put lemon juice in it that's
Billy Crystal from The Princess Bride
smell bad my name is Montoya you
killed my father prepared to die let's
just do the whole movie okay I'll be the
old man you be Fred Savage go oh no let
me be the old man can I be the old man
okay all right I got I got a great I
know you're sick got a great story for
this is a great this was a book that I
read when I was a little
boy I want to play games and
run shouldn't Daniel Stern's voice kick
head it was a moment like that that I
knew my Grandpa would die
soon one more thing you claim to be sick
but uh that's
Columbo oh my God I didn't realize that
was Columbo you know who's going to love
this episode
Farmers you know that was a big risk we
took cuz it was like the whole premise
of the monologue was I'm joking yeah no
I know you know what you know what I
mean not we're always joking but it was
like it was a joke so the fact that the
audience was like we'll go there made me
feel a warmth in my heart like ET I saw
a guy in coveralls get up and storm out
outrage I don't come here for this I do
like the thought of a farmer at home
being like let's give that guy a shot
you know uh you know that
fell he's a standup comedian I saw him
at uh the stress Factory one time this
guy's Fant what the hell Pitchfork at
the
TV not to perpetuate any stereotypes but
when Farmers don't like it they will
throw a pitchfork right at they're like
Elvis with guns of course then they
Shuffle to the kitchen for coffee that
we would consider too
strong just like in an old like like
like Cowboy Coffee yeah like it's like
it's it's solid matter not liquid right
right it's that dark matter they
discovered most of the world it's dark
matter that's what Farmers drink when
they're upset at Pete Holmes so you know
I'm glad you're on the show it's just
water I'm glad look I'm glad you're on
the show because uh people do think
we're the same person yeah I know I I
met you a couple days ago and we talked
about this yeah and I was like people
come up to me all the time and say
you're great on the mini project so much
so that I just say thank you now that's
I appreciate that that's good I go
thanks people people come to me like I I
saw you man at the Improv man you killed
yeah and I'm like that's not me that's
Pete Holmes oh you go honest yeah I do
cuz I don't want to no go ahead really
it's like that change up movie cuz you
you're married and have kids you could
be you could be me and just go home
alone and eat
soup that's what the change up was about
right I got to be Ryan Reynolds beep
beep
you're not picturing rotating soup it's
it's right here it's a Campbell's yeah
peel away lid we got it we're uh we're
improvising we actually did we came from
the same improv theater in Chicago
that's why we're both a little fat yeah
you got to you don't want anybody to go
this guy is not doughy enough to be
funny no there's never been someone
who's like I saw this improviser from
Chicago so funny so skinny right it
doesn't happen here's something we're
big people you got to be a big people
yeah I I like to you know when I'm doing
stand up I want people to go I'd like to
sleep on that man yeah yeah yeah oh he
looks like a like a I I could just talk
to him all night about my problems and
not have sex with him exactly yes what a
sweet doughy nonsexual threat yeah yeah
yeah that man that's oblong and kind of
shaped like a rhus oh he's like a he's
like a white Grimace I'm glad we're
being on camera at the same time and
proving to America once and for all we
are separate human beings we're separate
human beings Parent Trap someone though
though but but
IES and I smell bad you said it I got
you you look so stupid just
now I did get sweaty dancing
earlier is this The
Mentalist when does The Mentalist come
out you're the live taping of The
Mentalist right a good-looking
Australian is he a psychic I don't know
anything I don't know I I he can't be
can't they've been like 400 episodes he
can't constantly be like wait a
minute I know the murderer yeah no it's
impossible it's like house the third Act
of house he's like oh house was right
yeah at some point they just got to be
like in the first scene they're like
well house is right he's always right
right he's never been wrong right let
him take his pills he loves those pills
yes you ever you ever recreationally
enjoy a vikin I'm Stone right now are
you you did a little weat a weed smoke
your talent Booker gave gave me uh some
a handful of opiates before I came in
you're saying JP Buck gave you a handful
yes he's laughing right now but he's in
big trouble a handful yeah just a
handful of opiates I'm so wasted I'm so
horny I I talked to a young man in the
crowd who is very horny oh really yeah
he's 17 so that oh my God he's a a boner
he's a boner wearing shoes yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're a living
boner every woman you see you could see
Janet Reno like I want to have sex with
her right now yeah yeah it's a very
confusing time the good thing is that
that only lasts until you're like 75
that's I when I was a kid when I was his
age I used to worry that at some point I
would have to I don't know why God would
tell me you have to apologize to
everyone you've ever thought about while
masturbating oh my God that's like
Schindler's List I can't well no no not
because they're
Jewish because it's a long list of
thousands of people you could have said
Santa's
list but you went right to the Holocaust
the two whitest what are you I'm Jewish
though oh you're Jewish yeah so I got to
get out of jail free card those of you
who laughed at that choke you're
anti-semitic and your names are being
written down on the Hollywood
blog on the Hollywood blog Hollywood
blog I uh I worked at this office in
Chicago this uh I I want to say the name
CTA CTA Chicago Transit Authority that's
the name I'm aware of it I love the
Brown Line love what you did with the
brown thank you thank you thank you I'm
a green line guy um but I remember it
was like the early days of the internet
you know and one of the guys taught me
how to do like a Google image not even
Google back then like a yeah lyos
whatever the hell crawler web crawler
remember when you like this ask jees is
going
places already a butler and they just
started right now Jeeves is at some
retirement home being like when are they
going to ask me this is this is
but I remember you know I was doing
internet and I found like uh someone
posted photos online of remember
Madonna's book called sex yeah she had
like these very runchy photos you know
very tasteful erotic photos tasteful
erotic very very hot I remember I found
these and I was like oh my God these are
great I'm going to print these and then
later yes masturbated yeah yeah yeah you
you set a master date I set a master
date I did I was young so it's okay um
and I was like I'm going to print this
one click that's great click print
amazing print and I went over the
printer you know and it wasn't working
you know and it was like 4:48 on a
Friday afternoon so I was like screw
this I just turned the printer off then
Monday morning oh no my boss comes in
with a stack of images plops Dan like
Madonna like eating Vanilla Ice's butt
you know like plops down he's like uh
you can't use the internet anymore so
yeah really bit me in the ass then
Jeeves came out like Who's Laughing Now
you were quick to make fun of me earlier
weren't
you I uh one one final thing we're
almost uh I really we can wrap up
whenever but I want to make sure we get
this why'd you say that I don't know
unions no it's a union thing whenever
it's a Showbiz thing that I don't
understand yeah yeah un I'm so sorry I
we're going to have to have your car I
want your car it's a union issue I'm so
sorry mine now you uh you were on Matt
TV and I know you do some Impressions
and I I've been told you do a wonderful
Bane Bane from Batman Bane from Batman
yes I you do a great Batman
well I like the turn this is taken yes I
I I would imagine those guys together
when they're not fighting you're you're
setting it up like we planned it but we
we really H now I feel like the
expectation is like they're going to do
a
duet no no no no no you're just going to
hear the voices and then you're going to
go uh where do we park what if it's what
if it's um what if it's Batman and Bane
uh at Buffalo Wild Wings
okay we can get a different suggestion
by the way so this doesn't seem I I I
you know they are a sponsor okay then
Buffalo Wild great it's a great you know
what it's it's a great place to watch
the game and grab a beer brought to you
by heartburn at the
airport so
U are you thinking Bon with
bones here to go
boness so many sauces Batman so many
different sauces I'm thinking garlic
parmesan
myself I should do this
sorry ooh ooh ooh ooh they have they
have waffle fries
I like the waffle
fries shuffles in the morning fries in
their
lunchtime Seinfeld Batman so so maybe
maybe maybe we we get 20 wings and some
waffle fries and maybe we share a
dessert now you have my permission for
fries it's so
Gooding we'll be right back we'll be
right we said the
uh thanks to I bar H we'll be right back
with more show thanks Pete thanks Pete
you're the
[Music]
best